Please, we're living in a country, in England.
We're praying five times, there's mosques.
You know, the freedom is there, everything is there.
Whatever happens or is going on in the world, we don't have to explain...
...but we can do what we can do, and what we can do is we can win people with our attitude.
Nobody is disrespecting each other's culture here or religion here.
The most important thing in Britain is people let you do what you want to do.
And that's important.
English people are very open-hearted,...
...you know, they can accept your thing.
You know, I remember while I was playing professional cricket for Somerset,...
...my teammates used to tell me, "Is it your prayer time? Should we stop on some motorway services?"
"So, we can have a coffee, you can have your prayer."
So, you know, if you have that kind of people around you and that culture,...
...I don't think people will have any problem.
I was approached by England to become a spin bowling coach...
...and I said, "Why not?"
When Pakistan play in England, my feeling is that Pakistan obviously is my country...
...but my job allows me to be loyal with England and be honest with England.
There's plenty of fans, like Pakistani people, who actually lives in England but they support Pakistani cricketers.
You can support Pakistan, you know, when they're playing against England.
That's fair enough.
That's sport.
But please remember, you're living in a country where they provide you everything,...
...so you've got to be honest with them.
You're living in Britain so you've got to look after Britain.
If I didn't have this information of Islam, then maybe I would have a doubtful thinking.
But at the moment, I'm very clear and I have no doubt.